hello I am Nemo and ever my question is
if you are the violin what will be the
most beautiful moment you will ever have
experienced if I if you was divine if I
was if I was the violin what was that's
ever and who sits around young people
here if the violet well you know I the
violin becomes it's almost it's it is
kind of like a living thing I mean it
really the connection one feels with the
violin is almost like it is so you do
feel like this violin is responding to
the way you play it responds when you
play in tune it starts to open up the
sound which because the overtones ring
in a different way and the violence
starts to open up so it makes you think
that whoever played the violin
beforehand affects the way this violin
sounds now so if I were this violin I
mean this violin was I think I'd be very
pleased that that who Berman played on
me at one time I think that's quite a
privilege and I don't I don't know I
think to be played I think it's what the
violin was born to do and that's its
cause and its meaning and I think if
it's being played and beautiful music
you know the Bach Bach concerto of
chacón means nothing without the
instrument so so it's part of the
equation of something really truly great
which this is a sort of a combination of
Bach and the instrument and the player
all have to be together and all have to
work I have the luckiest job in the
world that I open up this case every day
to I go to work and I have a relic 17:13
Stradivari which we could have a whole
symposium just on violin making and and
the glories of a Stradivarius
I get to I get to be inspired by this
this amazing thing every day so so and I
and I only wish I knew all of the
stories that this violin does know
because I know a few I know about who
Berman and a couple of the owners before
but there's about 150 years where I
really have no idea who was playing on
this violin and and I'm sure there's
some great stories but I just don't know
what they are
thank you there was a very good question
thank you behind you
yes well I'm the SIA and I just want to
ask you what's going to rim mine when
you're playing your favorite song on the
filing yeah that's what's going through
through my mind it's it's it's a good
question and and I don't always even
know what how to answer that because as
an artist you're playing let's say ba
you really you you're getting inside the
mind of of the composer and of the
you're kind of like an actor in a way
it's a little simplified but I like an
actor taking on a role you just have to
a good actor really becomes the role if
you ask Meryl Streep what she's thinking
about when she plays plays the character
of some character she probably would say
she loses herself inside that character
and doesn't think about it she just is
that and the same thing is the same
thing with music you just have to become
become that music and what the end and
tell the story that the composer so when
the magic happens on stage when I feel
the best concerts when I feel I played
the best is often related to the degree
that I'm completely immersed myself the
brain is an amazing thing because it can
do multitask so you can play one thing
and you can be aware of the pretty girl
in the front row and and somebody
coughing in the back row but but but if
when you're really involved you blow it
you block all of that and then there
have been concerts where I play and I
feel I'm completely inside of the music
and people come back as he did you hear
that that that they came away and took
somebody from the second row who fainted
they took them away in a stretcher and
then that the people the coughing and
that's like I said I didn't even hear
thing you know because I'm immersed in
the music
you